every cigarette from you and then an
assignment finding best LP relaxations
for director car problems so everything
I'm gonna say I mean in every new result
and I'm gonna say it in this Hawk will
be based on some papers on either
published this year or some millet is a
written this year so it's interesting to
see how many people and how many papers
are involved here so for example Chandra
and Beckham had a really nice paper
introducing the problem of a multi-cat
age which is a special case of multi cut
when the demand graph is affixed to BH
they're on the same time I independently
has are some result about multi card
interdiction firefighter problems and
then based on these techniques and with
other on aquitine ideas we also looked
at global cut problems that I'm gonna
introduce later and then on my quarters
also worked on a very cool problem
called linear tariqa problem which is a
special case of a multi cut rh and then
they improve the optimal approximation
algorithm whose approximation ratio is
our square root of two then finally I
was talking to be back again and then we
came up with our optimal LP for multi
cottage for every um demand graph H and
then this will be the core might just
talk so let me start so our focus will
be a directed multi car problem it's a
very classical problem so in this
problem the input is very simple we're
gonna get directed graph G and then
capers s1 p1 through SKT K so in this
example and that goal is to remove the
knee more edges to make sure that in the
supply graph there's no path from SI 2
TI for every I so in this example if you
remove these two um edges then you can
see that there is no path from s 1 to t1
and there's no path from s to to t2 so
these two edges form a valid solution
for directed multi-cut then I'm sure
that they're they're gonna be at the
optimal solution ok so this is a very
classical problem and then it's been
studied a lot on previously so if you
want to write approximation algorithm in
terms of n then we already knew routine
approximation algorithm we chose by only
improved to n to the 11 over 23 I'm due
to travel alone in charka
and even from the lower bound side by
the nice work of Chilean canal we know
that full cut LP has a gap of at least
on entity one over seven and then this
problem is also np-hard to approximate
within almost polynomial factor okay so
there's a very interesting gap between 1
& 1 over 7 & 11 over 323 in the exponent
but we understand this problem pretty
well but if you want to express the
approximation ratio in terms of K and
let's suppose that K is some constant
then we know that there is very easy
care proximity algorithm just a computer
minimum SI TI cut and take the Union and
but we know that we can't improve upon
this easy care proxy algorithm using
just standard fluid LP ok when K is less
than log n we know that for cut gap is a
close to K so we can't improve our care
próxima shell with him and when what
Chandra and be back proved last year is
that even when K is 2 they prove that is
in if it's unique games hard to
approximate this problem within a factor
1.5 so from now on every hardness result
the representatives are based on unique
games itself I feel bad to present
unique games hardness after hearing that
indie games in almost every possible
setting but that's what I have so they
show this and then advise a new so 1.5
was the best of hardness constant for a
as long as K is constant so obviously
the hardness result to require that K
should be growing with n I think this is
almost polynomial and then for any
constant K 1.5 was the best hardness
ratio we could so on what happened in
2017 is that so Chandra and Rebecca and
I independently prove that undirected
multi cut with K pairs is a unique games
hard to approximate within a factor of K
so the trivial K approximation algorithm
is optimal so if I say something about
these two proofs so on the vacant
renders on proof is a reduction from min
CSP they will stratify any bone dragon
who and then they reveal the very
interesting connections between
different LP relaxations so if you think
about our cut problems than the first
standard LP you will think of is a full
cut cap flowcode LP but if you think of
a CSP then the first LT you think of is
labeling LP that gives you that gives us
some probability to some event that some
variable get some value so those are
like very different LPS but they on
established connections between these
are two LT relaxations so whereas my
proof is are based on like more or less
dry direct reduction from unique gains
so I didn't have a dis cool fact about
LPS but at least for me my proof was or
conceptually simpler and an easier to
adapt to other cut problems so but what
Chandler perfected that I didn't do is
to interest this a very cool problem of
multi-cat age so let each year fixed
demand graph say that it's a constant
size so given this age multi-cut H is a
special case of a undirected multikill
problem so now demand graph is fixed so
input is adjust supply graph mg and the
injective map PI from the vertices of
eight to versiv G so PI essentially um
specifies where the terminals are and
then give this input our goal is to be
on the minimum registry such that for
every edge UV of age we want to make
sure that in supply graph there is no
path from the image of view to image of
V in G so if H looks like this I may
just like single edge and G looks like
this then we can easily see that this
problem is exactly me nastika problem
that we can solve efficiently but we can
look at other eyes so if H looks like
this then if H is on this complete graph
complete directed acyclic graph and then
this problem is known as a linear k cut
when K is the number of vertices and
then this problem was also independently
studied so if you look at multi card H
in general then we know that it's gonna
have a easy eh approximation algorithm
when we're eh denotes the number of
edges of H and then the previous
hardness was all to show that it's gonna
be tight when HSR KDC edges but for some
H we know that we can be much better
than this so for example if H is a
complete by directed graph then this
problem is exactly directed multi a cut
and then we know to approximation for
every H
and if H is a complete diape directed
acyclic graph then this problem as I
described earlier it's called K linear
cut and then it has a Loki approximate
all working and then surprisingly it's a
flu cut gap is still open so it's still
possible that it automates a constant
approximation algorithm where the
constant doesn't depend on K Rho and
then as I said my quarters looked at on
this com3 linear cut problem and then
they got an optimal route approximation
algorithm due to matching the flow cut
gap so for some H we can do much better
and then interestingly all these
algorithms use a standard fluid LP okay
so that natural question is for some
fixed age so can you come up in a better
relaxation by adding many constraints so
that we can improve the slightly upon
the sender LP okay there was a question
well surprisingly the chanter be back
proof that when H is a directed piper
tight so by rejected bipartite I'm in
the graph like this so undirected margin
is bipartite and then every edges are
adding to the one direction so they
prove that when H is a directed
bipartite the multi-cut H is a unique
insert to approximate better than the
words floor cut cap okay so if H looks
like this then actually the flow cut LP
is the best help it you can write for so
then next natural question is what about
general H so unfortunately I couldn't
solve this problem so it's still
possible that our flow cut cap is the
best but what we proved instead is that
we came up with another LP relaxation or
I I prefer to present it as an
estimation algorithm that always output
to the lower bound of the optimal and
hopefully vehicles such that it's unique
games hard to do better than this some
LP relaxation were estimation algorithm
and then I want to introduce on this LP
relaxation so before going this on that
briefly look like some of the hardness
proof of the theorem by UM Chandra Vivek
and I'm gonna present an alternate proof
based on my previous paper so let's
first look at on what flow Cadell key is
so the first thing I'll do is that I
will consider a vertex addition version
in the vegetation version but we know
that there are all my key
by taking the line graph so everything
is the same the only restriction is that
cannot delete terminals which is
completely natural and let's say T is a
set of terminals
this is LP we wanted to minimize the
summation of X V where V is summed over
the set of non terminals such that for
each path from the image of view to
image of V for every mu V in the demand
graph we want that the summation of X V
is at least one so this like very
standard constraint and the next must be
non-negative okay that's it so that's a
prisoner LP but as I described earlier
it's gonna have a gap so suppose that H
looks like this HS are to these three
edges and then G looks like this and you
can easily see that opt is at least two
because of deleting just one vertex will
not do the job if you just delete just
one vertex then either as one can reach
T 1 whereas 2 can reach T 2 but you can
also notice that every s 1 T 1 path or
every s 2 T 2 paths must involve at
least 3 internal vertices so which means
that if I give em one third to every non
from the vertex then it's gonna be
feasible for this LP so the LP values at
most 4/3
so there's a gap about 1.5 so I also
should mention that for this some demand
graph if H is a to these three edges be
actually on the optimal LP gap you will
be approaching to to but I'm just like
using this 1.5 as for simplicity okay so
given this LP so let's try to prepare
this so the first thing I will do is I
will decide something called dictator
test for me it's just another instance
of multi cottage and so the first first
transfer which I will do is I'll replace
every internal vertex by something
called hypercube L to the arc so so this
is a given instance then I'm gonna
replace every non-terminal vertex by a
hypercube like this so here L is 3 and R
is 2 but like they're just numbers they
don't matter too much here so and then
I'm gonna put edges so i'm not gonna i'm
show details but the only thing I'm
gonna say is that if you V
he was an edge of the supply graph in
that gap insist then we were going to
create some edges between corresponding
hyper appropriately so this is all I'm
going to say about the clear test and
then once we have some declared test
with some desired properties then what
we will eventually do so we want it to
prove unique in hardness so we want to
reduce from unit games so so as you saw
instance of unique games and it just
like one graph and then each edge is
some constraint and then the goal is to
give a label to each vertex to maximize
the number of satisfied edges so suppose
that this some graph with two vertices
and one edge is our very hard unique
games instance and then so to prove that
to reduce this instance to multi-core
insist so what I'm gonna do is that I'm
gonna replace each unique games vertex
by this gigantic
the clear test I constructed earlier and
then you see some problems because we
have a multiple copies of the same term
though which we are not allowed to so
I'm gonna just combine these terminals
and then I'm gonna replace this blue
unique games edge by multiple edges
between the there dictator test again
appropriately some echinacea details and
then in the yes case um if unique games
has a cool labeling then I'm gonna prove
that I just proved that there's some
chemical solution slicing one sites from
each hypercube that's gonna be good for
that's gonna be cheap and will do the
job and but it's not gonna work if
unique games is not good and then
essentially if unique games instance is
not good and only thing we could do is a
entirely remove one hypercube or not so
we are going back to the the analyzing
integral solution of the gap instance
and that's where the gap comes from okay
so I didn't show anything but this is
like very high-level idea of how the
hardness works so yeah suppose that we
prove directed by protecta see in this
manner so what is wrong at general h so
for a general h this is actually this is
not general h is a still directed by
particle but one crucial trick I use for
directed bipartite case is that for
directed bipartite case we know that in
H every vertex is our source or sink
and then if we have this and actually
then for every capensis
we can also assume that every terminal
is our source or sink so we can easily
compute source of this and then this was
kind of crucial in my reduction suppose
that yeah suppose that we have generate
even though like this is a generate but
suppose that we about this piloted edges
between one terminal and then one
non-terminal vertex then actually but in
the in the eyes of LP I didn't change
the instance at all so the same LP
solution will work so but somehow my
reduction doesn't work at all
so main reason is because of my
reduction was to P but actually but the
main reason my reaction was stupid is
that so that if you look at the LP
solution then the distance between s 1
and T 1 is 1 as required that's all what
is required for LP but the distance
between s 1 s 2 is our only 2/3 which is
a strict less than 1 and then this
starts between as 21 is also a logic
less than 1 okay so in some part of the
proof I wanted to prove that s 1 T 1 is
disconnected if it removed or some
chemical solutions but what someone can
do is someone can start from s 1 and
then go to s 2 it was possible because s
1 s 2 LP distance was a less than 1 and
then because as 2 is our single vertex
you refresh you can refresh everything
you can do as if you started from s 2
and then you can reach T 1 so this is
like very high level idea but somehow so
this some fact was a troublesome for me
so I was really very just disappointing
for a while but actually one I realized
that I realized what one trivial
observation such that in order to cut s
1 from T 1 we need to cut either cut
either as 1 from s 2 or as 2 from T 1 so
this failure in proving hard is somehow
inspired me to go to talk with him so
sorry for like this hand wavy hardness
let's go to UM Chris Paul Gordon so here
is algorithm so algorithm fits in this
box so it's a very simple so let's say
that directed graph F is unambiguous if
for every R HUV of this some graph and
every third vertex W either you double
is an edge or WB is an edge so if you
interpret F as a demand graph which you
will it means that if you want to cut UV
then you need to cut either you W where
W V which is very natural okay so and
then it's if you want to saying that the
directly compliment of AB is a
transitive graph so so given this
definition here is algorithm I'm gonna
describe a so estimation algorithm first
on this problem which will um output
single value which is only the lower
bound of the opt so given us a plug FG
we're going to try every possible
unambiguous app I'm on the same set of
vertices with a V H and then um F should
be a super graph of H you know edgy
inclusion right sense and then we're
going to compute local relaxation value
which I'll denote as LP f of G for every
possible app and then output the minimum
value so that is all my algorithm and
then is it in at first it looks kind of
bizarre and then it's not clear whether
there's a relaxation or not so let's try
to see so this is algorithm so one thing
you can easily establish is that for
every F or since F with a super graph of
H so we know that LP h g is our at most
LP f of g that's true
and I claim that um there exists F among
the graph we considered such that LP FG
is at most opt Hg okay so let's try to
say this okay so look at this example
okay so we have h and we have G and then
suppose that we have a some optimal
phocion so delete this optimal solution
from the graph so after after doing this
optimization we can see that at all the
code requirements given by H are met but
if you look at the supply graph after
the Ling opt then we can real we can see
that actually we delete it much more
than we needed
okay so actually in in this example as
well as two are completely separated and
then T t1 and t2 do not have any
outgoing edges are all so if you
construct another like demand graph F
with the same set of vertices so today
I'm gonna put on edge from u to V if
there's no path from u to V here
then the resulting f in this case will
be complete by directed graph so this is
only for this example but you can easily
convince yourself that for any H for any
G and for me for any optimal solution
actually for any feasible solution the
resulting F construct in this way will
be always unambiguous okay that's
obvious because if you cut you to V then
you must cut you to W or W to B so this
proves that there exists RF that we
considered and we're up to FG or equal
to opt HG so and then we just proved
that there exists there is a such as LP
of GSR and most optic h3cz effects and
then we know that um yeah the value
output by our algorithm which I'll
denote as um al HG is ascending should
between opt and LP okay so it's gonna be
always of relaxation and then for any
instance it's gonna do as good as up the
LP so I am stating this algorithm as a
estimation algorithm but if you really
want you can um these can be captured as
a single LP by running a fluid LP for
every possible via by blowing factorable
sides of vector about 2 to the K square
so but I didn't present a LP so what
does a gap of this algorithm in perfect
H so I'm going to claim that on the gap
means on am biggest F and G such that LP
FG is our less than optic G again it
looks kinda bizarre because we're
comparing apple and orange but at least
I show that there is a some elf that LP
values are less than opt so I'm not
asking you to do the impossible thing
and then and then actually it's true
that I'm asking you to do to present you
present me a stronger capensis
and then the theorem is actually says
that for every fixed edge a gap of this
algorithm implies the matching unique in
hardness the proof proof is is
essentially the same and then I just
resolve this issue of all the bypassing
so I think this algorithm is on is also
very natural but it it's
become more natural if we consider
undirected analogue by the way that's
the running time of this algorithm to to
the case carat identity constant so it
can be called as FPT approximation
algorithm so if you look at the
undirected on analog then unambiguous
app means a complete P part I graph for
like some P which means that complement
is or just like disjoint clicks union of
gesturing clicks so so if you look at
the algorithm the outgoing is just like
essentially guessing which terminals
belong together in the optimal solution
and then run multi-vehicle algorithm
then we saw Monday that um for any
instance of multi away cut algorithm we
are gonna get 1.3 approximation so for
every H multi-card H in under the
multi-core age and can be approximate
within a factor 1.3 if we allow time K
to the K times our entry constant this
is really good but again if you really
really really care about the optimal
approximation ratio for the fixed age
then you can try to find the gap insist
which is our name because F and G search
that on the earthmover LP jlp for the
multi a cut or means the less than
optimum hn g and then but we already
know the earthmover LP is a proved to be
optimal for multi rate cut so i haven't
verified this but it's very conceivable
that there proof already proved that
this our this algorithm is the best
estimation algorithm for it under the
multi-core age if you really care about
the approximation factor between 1 and 1
point 3 so this is all i wanted to say
about multi cut and so as I promised I'm
gonna say something about the global cut
problems
so suppose let's consider the SP by cut
which is not global version so ft by cut
is a special case of a multi-cat age
when H is a by directed edge between s
and T so the problem is given G and SN T
so we are given terminals we were to
remove the minimum rod such that there
is no fppad and TS path so the global
bucket as you defined is a problem we
are given a graph G we want to minimum
number arcs such that there exist two
vertices on where there's no TS d % es
path ok so we can choose where to put
aminals to minimize or cut value okay so
these on this relationship is a very
similar to
between three we couldn't record so we
cut we have a graph G and s tu in
undirected graph and then we want to
remove the mean Reggie such that they
are separated and then three cut um
one way to view it is on it to view this
problem is that given a graph G we want
to remove the minimum Reggie such that
there exists some three parties they are
separated and then we know that this
problem is np-hard and this probably is
NP so and then we observe the similar
phenomenon here as well even though in
the approximation sense so ft by cut on
by earlier arm work we know that it is
all unique and hard to approximate in a
factor of two but I mean this our later
work or we prove that global by cut and
something slightly better than to
approximation so there's like some non
trivial distinction here so and so this
was for the global cut and then in the
earlier paper our I also proved the
first some super constant higher
hardness for like various cut problems
code length bounded cut shirts path
injection and firefighter so they're all
based on the single framework that I am
named as out lengths control dictation
test so it is just taking some LP cap
instances to unique aims houses you know
very similar manner on that I just
showed you earlier and so one like
personal application is that can you
prove harness over worker problems that
were open and actually so I what I
really wanted is that I wanted a general
theorem that unifies all current results
so so far I just had to look at every
problem individually and then see their
LP capensis and then see whether my
proof was there or not and but I really
wanted a general theorem that unifies
many problems but um I was talking and
then main reason is that I don't know
how to like formally unify various cut
problems I think so these type of the
optimal results were known for Mac CSP
and then CSP is a very general it's a
very good on framework that unifies many
problems but for cut problems I didn't
know how to do it so yeah that's all one
personal goal so and then like we have
many other open problems in this
direction so actually the immediate open
problem is to see whether flow cut gap
boca del P will be optimal for
directly multi-core age it's gonna have
a practical impact because that's gonna
save us on to three case care time so
and then the answer can be negative in
the sense that we have an instance G and
H such that LP on HG is are strictly
less than alpha HT so there if you fix
both supply graph and demand graph then
there's a there's an example where LP
those are strictly worse than this but
we are interesting the worst-possible
gap for fixed age so it's still possible
that for every H if you picks H and then
take the maximum gap then they made it
may be the same so it's like very
immediate open problem and then another
open problem is to find the interesting
H where can do much better than our
distributor approximation so we know
this for we know this for multi a con a
linear k cut and then as I said they all
use a fluid LP so maybe you can do much
better for some other H I'm using the
new LP and then the final open question
is to find the optimal rounding
algorithm so I just ate it as a
estimation algorithm and where LP but I
don't know how to run it and then this
problem also exists in the earlier work
of MN RS or evw where they show that
certain LP is optimal for undirected
multi a cut or means GSP so somehow Mac
CSP we know that some STP is optimal and
then we know rounded at least
theoretically but for these problems
these around our there are missing so
that's gonna be very good research
direction to study thank you
[Applause]
you know long
[Applause]